Anna and Elsa are one powerful set of
Disney sisters but even these two have
some limits to their power
check out these 10 strict rules that on
an Elsa have to follow in frozen powers
for this room always wear gloves when
Elsa and Otto were little on a knew all
about Elsa's powers but after Anna was
struck in the head by ice everything
changed the trolls were able to save her
but their parents were super scared that
pond his life would be put in jeopardy
again he had gloves specially made for
Elsa these gloves aren't just regular
old mittens they are powerful enough to
keep Elsa's powers in check when she
wears them she can't turn anything into
ice we wonder what they're made of
Elsa's parents required her to wear them
all the time and Elsa keeps wearing them
even after her parents are gone she's
super scared her powers will go out of
control
without them don't socialize with other
people Elsa and her parents are
terrified of her powers so they for
Sanne to grow up totally isolated they
close down the castle from the rest of
arendelle and also won't play with her
sister at all she stays in her room all
day Anna doesn't understand why her best
friend and sister has suddenly abandoned
her but because also his powers are a
secret Anna can't have any other friends
either it's really sad
surely there were some other kids in
arendelle that she could play with and
it also was in a room all the time why
couldn't someone just come to visit this
rule was totally unfair keep the gates
closed my powers for the best we aren't
sure exactly what their parents were
thinking with this next role apparently
they were so scared of Elsa's magic that
they didn't want to see any other people
maybe they were scared that Elsa would
cause a natural disaster or maybe they
were afraid someone would hurt Elsa
because of her powers but the king and
queen closed down arendelle from the
rest of the world they stopped trading
with other countries and they wouldn't
let anyone in or out of the castle after
they were lost at sea
Elsa kept this rule in place she was
really scared of opening up the world
tour powers secrets and exploit your
riches keep your powers a secret when
Ana was really young she knew all about
Elsa's magical powers
but after Elsa hid Anna with her icy
magic the trolls removed on his memories
of it can be persuaded
do what you must she remembered playing
without a but she didn't remember the
powers and also was forbidden from
telling her sister about it that's a
pretty big secret to keep from your
little sister and it made on a totally
shocked when Elsa's powers were revealed
at the coronation conceal don't feel
Elsa's powers are fueled by her emotions
when her emotions get the best of her
her powers are too strong to handle to
keep her magic under control her dad
came up with a little rhyme for her
this became Elsa's number one rule
this means that she should hide all of
her feelings instead of letting herself
feel them it's a really sad thing that
she had to learn at such a young age of
course leader she learned that feeling
her emotions allowed her to control her
magic even better we're just glad that
Elsa finally decided to let it go don't
marry someone you just met something
crazy will you marry me okay this rule
is actually the best rule Anna had never
been around other people when Elsa opens
the gates of arendelle Anna meets Hans
he's handsome he's charming and he's
everything on a ever wanted in a husband
of course Hans turns out to be a bad guy
Anna wants to marry him even though they
have only known each other for a few
hours
else out refuses you can't marry a man
you just met this turns out to be a
really good rule Elsa's magic rules
Elsa's magic seems to be all powerful
she was able to turn arendelle into a
natural disaster zone but she does have
some rules she has to follow when it
comes to her abilities the main one is
that her magic is limited to ice and
snow still the things she can do with
ice is pretty unlimited she can make
snowmen and snow monsters come to light
she can even make herself a dress too or
a massively beautiful snow castle you
can't freeze the ocean
this next rule comes from the frozen to
trailer Elsa is seen trying to use her
magic to freeze the sea but it's turning
out to be a lot harder than freezing a
small body of water on top of that it's
more challenging to freeze salt water
than regular water in fact the sea has
to be quite a bit colder than regular
water to freeze Elsa may be magical but
she even has to listen to the laws of
science we bet she figures it out though
she just has to make things even colder
[Music]
travel by foot this next rule is a
theory that we have from the frozen to
trailer Elsa is obviously trying to
freeze the sea so she can walk on it and
we know that on an outside travel
somewhere in the new movie but if they
need to travel by sea why can't they
take a boat maybe Elsa's magic won't let
her travel by sea or maybe the girls are
scared of the sea because that's how
their parents passed away we can't wait
to figure this out in the new movie I
won't let anything happen to her love
conquers all when also first sets off
the perpetual winter in arendelle she
has no clue how to control it
she can't even reverse it but the trolls
tell Anna about the true love rule only
an act of true love can thaw a frozen
heart honest sacrifices herself for Elsa
because she loves her sister and that
ends up saving her Elsa figures out that
love is the emotion that lets her
control her powers and keep everyone
safe before you go tell us who your
favorite frozen sister is in the
comments section below
and that's a wrap don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and be sure
to hit that subscribe button for the
latest Disney news thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]